raise my case yes this one was all
listener and viewer submissions and they
did a good job the first one a 23 year
old man who works as a sitter for a
blank hospital is facing charges after
getting caught sucking a sleeping
patients toast oh yeah he was arrested
for battery on a person 65 years or
older hmm the victim told police they
woke up around 11:00 p.m. and felt
someone touching their foot they thought
it was a nurse initially but it happened
two more times and when they looked up
the perpetrator was kneeling over them
with their lips on though he did take a
knee though yes my god white guy it's a
white guy yeah easy if it were a brother
he would have lit a couple candles he'd
have some chocolates or something he
would have been it would have been a
full plan yeah if it's just a
miscellaneous some guy sucking on a foot
I don't know dude that's that's a white
[ __ ] sucking I'm random feet but it's
also a hospital it's a hospital worker
yeah was it was it was it the big toe do
we know which toe it was cuz pink I know
black I mean the big toe looks the best
I think it's got to be the big toe right
yeah bad does play voice yes the
wisconsin' a big juicy all right give me
that big white hitter right I'm gonna
say honestly you got a lot of Polly's
over there in the you got a lot of the
mallanna's huh I'm talking about
Filipinos Eddie oh okay you got a lot of
um you got a lot of Filipinos in the
nursing industry I'm going Filipino a
lot of Manny Pacquiao's but I don't
think they're sucking on toes Filipinos
ain't sucking on toes this is white boy
all goddamn day
really yes I don't know a lot of white
people I feel like yeah maybe okay fine
I'll do I'll do okay fine all these
shows huh you suck on somebody's toes I
probably wouldn't I don't really have
time to do it
well let's say you had time one night
like let's say you took my wedding let's
say you took a break between Dateline
and your casserole and just some ten
came over with her [ __ ] pretty feet I
said suck em daddy suck em ruffles suck
does she have more of a female voice or
your voice well let me try to get some
ruffles [ __ ] suck em ruffle
that's how she talks Rock'em Sock'em
ruffles sucking [ __ ] Rock'em Sock'em
ruffles I'd have a little I'm not
staying down there long all right you do
it though I knew it they gotta be
licking some sweaty feet father clean
brats are mouthwatering when we brought
it up what do you think that I'm gonna
go with black only because the only time
I heard about guys sucking on girl's
toes was when I was like 10 watching I
Love New York and there was a bathtub so
now I think like toe-sucking I think
black dudes yeah
and it's yet noob dog dr. Dre song I hit
one ridin my one second my toes oh
you're beeping stuff out there eight
Mile Knicks back you want another crack
at it bro is that what's going on now
you're beeping out things all these but
is that I mean you do a toes though one
of the lines is one ride my dick right
one riding my dick the other suckin on
these toes okay so we got to black we
got a Filipino we got a wife I got a
white I wanna say black to you going
black why here black dudes both feet do
you suck on feet do I know you don't
that's surprising to me I know it is I
don't know I feel no one sucks on toes
in here I've never done it cat all right
suck on your toes they wanna leave the
internet would ya matter of fact I think
if we if you wanted to cut one of your
toes even you just wanna make replicas
of them yeah Selma's little toys yeah
yeah like a flashlight it's a toe light
chin what do you got I got I immediately
thought black 100% wow this is
surprising nobody's just everybody black
like we they eat wild stuff man thank
you do all right what do you got Nick
France Bell Doren friend's boyfriend why
he's black
Lee County Florida yeah he's a nurse I
don't think I don't think either of us
did you would you said Filipino I said
white I'll think you know I've ever got
one of these well then uh good we're not
well I think you're not cops
you know cater to detectives a 34 year
old woman pretended to be a high school
student for nearly entire school year at
she posed as a sophomore black she
fooled teachers classmates and even the
woman who took her in black the woman
who the girl had been living with was
dumbfounded she acted like a kid she did
her homework she got good report cards
the woman told ABC News the woman who
took her in had been the girls caregiver
since March after meeting the woman at
McDonald's where they both worked she
said she said the girl told her she
needed a place to stay after her parents
died and her sister was kicked out of
the apartment oh this is tough because
there's a few ways for the woman who
took her in was 30 the the girl who
posed as the sophomore was 34 here's the
thing here's the thing what is a
detective let's put on true detective
cabs here's the thing here okay I don't
know too many white girls who could who
are 34 who could pass as high school
students a white girl yeah unless she's
real tiny you know Asians really don't
age and then black girls - they don't
age till they get to a certain age yeah
yeah yeah I don't wanna double down on a
day you finished in our respective ANA
team or there wasn't one yet wasn't
working I Sally yep um so what are you
trying to say then she's doing a lot of
homework she's doing like a ton of
homework she even kept up a presence on
social media she posted for selfies and
his acquaintance bails dude that's what
I want to know
it is not quite in veils no I'm gonna go
Asian I'm going Asian because a lot of
homework yeah the homework but also the
thing at the end the sister got kicked
out of the home that's a very kind of
Asian kind of thing or something I don't
think there's a lot of some cultures
where they eliminate the female child so
I felt like that was a little bit of
possible give away and hold her age yeah
and also just so cuz some of the aging
why people age a lot more like people
age like fruit yeah yeah you can see it
do yeah you got a really you got to cut
in within a couple of days but we go bad
man and it's uh that's where I'm at I'm
14 years old
alright what do you think that I'm gonna
go with Asian just cuz this sounds like
every like kdrama ever mmm okay drama is
that like kpop like soap opera so nice
and you're second in this gym 100% Asian
yeah yeah agent agent charity Wow hold
on the girl on the right [ __ ] Warren
Sapp on the right someone bought that
she's in high school we see in what
world now I could see that she's a
rubenesque woman sometimes when you were
bigger like that you can kind of hide
what's you know you can kind of hide a
little bit you don't know you put it Li
shus hiding on Monday Night Football
Marla why are you bossing him they're
going to school she can't learn what's
the clock somebody's working exactly
going to school it's how they're going
to J and doing a ton of homework and get
crazy that's a great point
all she was charged with was failure to
show identification awesome she got a
$500 fan fine did you get that busted
mug shot though yeah what are you gonna
do it like that
but also that's on $500 that's on her
she looks that way you know yeah but
like you get ready for school every day
all hunter you know in the middle of the
night if you she might have a test the
next day the mighty got her in the
middle of night yeah let's crack this
case yeah they might equator go [ __ ]
police ops men I got her after a rough
Key Club meeting yeah
you just never know thank you guys for
getting the Key Club reference you were
I was too what was it it was a
volunteering club where you would just
be able to put on your college
application you're in key clothes in it
I just didn't know what we did but I'd
like to and surely get some friends yeah
I even went to like the met the
convention or something I just don't
know what would you do cut it's just
extra curricular stuff so you can sign
up to volunteer for like working at
marathons handing out water bottles just
little things like that helping the
community damn I thought it was for sick
I thought it was for singing he's always
remember thinking who the [ __ ] is
singing bro because never saying yeah
thought maybe the debate club or some
[ __ ] no no I remember the debate club
thing but this was I thought it was
singing brah but whatever man I'm still
confused what is key you want to sing on
key yeah I got you bro thank you man you
were the only one singing yeah I thought
it was for locksmiths did you too much
control we're on the last case and this
is this will round out the show case
number three a woman was arrested after
anger angrily screaming at a Tim Hortons
server before she leaned against a wall
pulled down her pants and defecated on
the floor I white go crazy white girl
didn't get her coffee she then picked up
her feces and flung it at the employee
hello
and then wiped her butt and threw with
napkins and threw those as well hell
yeah that's the worst I was throwing the
napkins they don't even go far they do
if you got Dookie on the ends yeah you
travel a little farther like that game
that the game with the red
Badman that's like that bit but was [ __ ]
the shuttlecock yeah
let's wake her all day this is so easy
also I get it Tim Hortons or copy sucks
I love to watch it so weak you know Tim
Horton was yeah I do
Canadian great [ __ ] hockey player
yeah the old Timmy Horton any bad coffee
though I think he died but he might not
have but what I will say is that I think
yeah this is a white woman probably
drug-induced I'm guessing somebody on
drugs already important now I gotta be
honest I I relate this lay sometimes
when white coffee is taking too long as
she comes weak I want to [ __ ] on the
floor I get it yes and too bad dude a
long time ago you could [ __ ] on the
floor [ __ ] on the floor and leave tell
you know this like basically leaving a
bad review yeah it was basically the
original yell most people [ __ ] after
their coffee yeah not this lady like I'm
gonna show you this is diseases case
we've had white girl all day Dan and
yeah I'll go white yeah I must say white
because it sounds like this punk rocker
I know name GG Allin oh you was shittin
o on stage and you throw it at people in
the crowd dude
yeah you'd [ __ ] on stage with Tony
because yes what a great what a VIP
experience I mean he did but I say white
white the unknown name of the assailant
she was white Wow - is it and we do have
video I don't know if I'd love to sit
she looks like she has her [ __ ] together
I'll sit no pun intended
I'm gonna sitting here while you guys
watch it okay see she has like a nice
scarf she has jewelry on she's not
homeless I'll be there she was guys she
was headed to [ __ ] I don't know maybe
a nice day at like IKEA going to pick up
a coffee shop see yelling
should you know what you know what
she'll like she want to use the bathroom
they said no oh wow all right I'm gonna
look away now okay she'll know what's
happening oh wow the guys like man
Oh what happened and she GG drop the hot
hot pile of [ __ ] bro I picked it on not
say it like a little bit
picked it up like a [ __ ] hacky sack
and threw it at the dude there was no
hesitation when she picked it up no good
arm
listen arm you look back to evolutions
evolution you you were right the napkin
to not go over well they kind of fizzled
yep
that's it that's the tough part about
doing that kind of thing yeah yeah you
don't really think about that you know
just when you got explosive diarrhea man
you got to go do you
that's how it ends brother that's how
this ends dude that's how it is baby
that Tim
[Music]